avec nos pierrefitte qu'ibn ministre de
l'économie bonsoir monsieur fait de
bonnes choses entrevues lio je fait que
benon comprends le désir quand même de
bien si des segments de l'économie la
construction le secteur manufacturier
les commerçants de reprendre mais est-ce
que j'ai raison de dire qu'il ya quand
même une forme d'audace de la part du
québec d'aller plus vite que certains
partenaires
si on a vraiment de consulter beaucoup
de jeunes ce milieu on oserait il est
très étroitement de santé publique
d'évidence on a travaillé aussi avec la
csst la question du protocole de retour
au travail
je pense que la séquence on note du 4
mai au 25 me on va réitérer au mot
remettre plus tôt dans le marché quatre
cent cinquante mille employés sur un
point du million tournée de 10 km est
temporaire je pensais quand même solide
est fermée mais des fondations à cette
relation
mais effectivement relevé le défi vivez
là c'est cette équipe qui entourent
l'économie et à combien vous évaluez ne
risque de votre projet de cette phase 1
qui ramène quatre cent cinquante mille
travailleurs pt je pense qu'on a
témoigné moins lundi jette un point
presse s'il y avait des répétitions et
des choses ne porte pas perdre et un
exemple e-commerce
on va commencer à les commerces de 4 me
au québec sont déçus et fier même sauvé
à montréal et à des choses que
malheureuses produire du goût de la
propagation
on pourrait le faire vélo c'est ce qu'on
veut pas faire ça même chose pour les
entreprises manufacturières nous avons
annoncé le 11 mai où on aurait 50
employés plus la moitié de l'excédent
est le reste 25 min son regard 11,25 les
propres créations importantes au niveau
des vingt-sept saunier on a des médias
nice mais selon moi pour pouvoir
s'ajuster aux besoins
nous avons évalué tué de 15 ans et à
faire des gens compétents du milieu est
d'autant plus qu'on a aussi consulté les
entreprises
moi j'étais en contact depuis trois
semaines
boudina façon constante avec moi et
plusieurs personnes seraient alors
surtout qu'ils sont très précis tout le
travail qui doit être fait pour
permettre de rehaussement le sanitaire
je pense qu'il va être notre stop alors
commerce de détail avec qui porte sur
rue là un salon de coiffure
massothérapie aide et non un peu à
comprendre ça veut dire quoi exactement
comment de commerce on veut une demande
de places où on sort comme ça qu'ils
aient honte à lui 22 lieux j où il a
fait qu une ex et extérieurs dont bad
arolsen d'achat donc sans la chose enfin
ce vote reporté à plus tard alors tout
de commerce qui à l'opération qui est
sûr eu plus recevoir des gens et les
règles à part ceux qui vont être mis sur
celui ci ait nécessité va 3-1 pour la
construction des jo no 1 pour les
commerces une adresse 24 soldats très
classe se dérègle confinement tout ce
qu'ils sentent et de ce public donc un
soin personnel ça va être tarder à plus
tard ok est-ce que vous avez vous avez
sûrement là mais les détaillants les
chantres et comment on va vérifier le
respect des lignes directrices de la
finance est petit livre des
vérifications d'usagé mosphere
évidemment on ouvre on demande aux
sociétés qui vont réouvrir respecter ces
règles
c'est des règles sont très très sympa
maintenant très clair qu'il ya des
mécanismes comme de nuit ciel pour voir
des talismans et on ne prend pas au
sérieux tout genre pour respecter ces
sociétés dû par ce n'est pas adéquat
pour les en communiquant avec des
sciences y en attendant avec des
fonctions on verra on verra je suis pas
d'accord je joue la soeur ont été dites
et les mécanismes basés aux jantes et
envoie respectives devraient fermer dans
cette sélection sans voiture est ce
qu'on comprend que l'objectif n'est plus
aujourd'hui de ralentir ou de vaincre de
virus mais de vivre avec
dans le fond au kilo de thon
si on devront du baroudeur évidemment ne
le travail les permis étaient travaillés
avec sa république
regardez à quel rythme vous voulez vous
prendre évidemment eux se préoccuper de
la propagation additionnel du livre sur
c'est clair que la truite façon ne pas
accélérer propagation fameuse courbe
fabuleux plateau et c'était
diversification discale des oignons ega
pas ça pour dire qu'elle quittait son
brevet puis le clan qu'on a présentement
qui à 2 450 milles entre potentiel qui
vont retourner d'ici 25 des étangs à
l'image est ce que sont des publics
trois importants pour respecter et les
autres et emploie justement parce que
vous mentionniez 1200000 québécois là
qui ont qui ont été en arrêt travail
sont en arrêt de travail autrement dit
la phase 2 et les pour kbc donc il
demain on a voulu garder une flexibilité
et un panda passons au restaurant
pensons où vous avez passé des touristes
de ce soin 61 87 e maîtrise encore non
d'urgence on regarde présentement tout
ce secteur au jeu devrait être de même
sur la montagne ou de la restauration
on a deux cent mille personnes dans
l'installation van hamme avoir double
culture story ce sujet regardons les
initiatives et ça va être très serré
pour de vote dans le retour et
d'économie aujourd'hui on voulait parler
de détroit pas un comic con à thiviers
450 mille emplois en juillet soit au fur
et à mesure que les données au niveau du
de containement de du livre sont
satisfaisants pour son public
mais quand même d'autres étapes province
ont donné des phases 2d phase iii on n'a
pas toujours les dates et chacun fait à
sa manière mais question planification
l'heure pour les lieux de diffusion en
culture ou pour les restaurants par
exemple parce qu'on ne seriez pas pu en
dire davantage aujourd'hui puisque vous
n'avez dit quand même beaucoup sur la
phase sera toujours des dap de
lointaines les mouches france pour sa
part celui ci devait pas prendre la vie
mentionné fusion c'est que les
entreprises b porte mais quel est ce
thème se préparer aujourd'hui les
commerces adore montréal
ces mêmes quand je suis au cameroun et
les commerces de la cnm on se construit
alors je pense que c'est suffisant comme
temporaire des installations on va voter
soins de santé on va de lignes rouges un
peu de temps au préalable se veut par
ailleurs je pense que de livres en
juillet contre na vi et conséquent f40
saison touristique au québec cet été
actée ma collègue karine tougas
attentivement on regarde beaucoup
j'espère du tourisme est le québec reste
cette année pour permettre aux gens de
retourner dans différentes régions ont
refait façon ordonnée évidemment encore
une fois avec le respect vis à vis une
sortie publique et donc dans les
prochains jours ça y est
merci beaucoup monsieur fait garonne